on en parle avec l'éditorialiste alexis
poulain un bon jour à l'équipe poulain
merci de répondre à nos questions
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter la
décision du conseil d'état d'annuler
donc ces deux dispositions mais de ne
pas remettre en cause de durcissement
des conditions d'affiliation qui
l'introduction d'une dégressivité pour
les hauts revenus le conseil d'état a
regardé ses traits forme en état et il a
vu qu'il y avait un problème d'égalité
face à la loi puisque dans le cadre de
la réduction des taux journaliers pour
un même travail on aurait pu avoir des
taux très différent puisque était pris
en compte non pas le salaire journalier
mais mensuel et que en fonction des
périodes d'inactivité pris en compte
dans le nouveau calcul eh bien on aurait
pu avoir beaucoup moins c'était plus de
huit cent quarante mille personnes qui
auraient pu voir leur indemnisation
réduite de 25% quasiment donc il fallait
assurer l'égalité devant la loi c'est ce
qu'a fait le conseil d'état et ce qui
est incroyable c'est le nombre de loi
finalement qui semble être très mal
écrites ou écrites en méconnaissance du
droit par cette majorité puisque on a eu
beaucoup de lois qui passent à la
moulinette du conséquence ionel ou du
conseil d'état et qui se retrouve être
jugée anticonstitutionnelle ou pas du
tout adapté donc la ministre du travail
a dit revoir la copie on attend de voir
la suite
justement qu'est ce qu'elle va proposer
ou qu'est ce que vous propose
proposeriez justement par rapport à
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage
alors aujourd'hui beaucoup de syndicats
souhaitent que cette réforme soit
simplement annulés mise à la poubelle
dans son intégralité
compte tenu de la crise sanitaire du coc
vie d'un cri est là depuis le mois
d'action qui eux ont ratifié le texte
oui oui bien sûr certains syndicats ont
ratifié mais il y a aujourd'hui une
vraie inquiétude de voir cette réforme
arrivé à terme et finalement dans un
moment où elle n'a pas lieu d'être
regarder l'actualité on parle de plans
sociaux après plans sociaux dans des
grandes entreprises
on parle de pme et tpe qui vont mettre
la clé sous la porte puisque malgré les
aides promises par le gouvernement
ce sera extrêmement difficile de
retrouver un niveau d'activité de
davant qu'ovide une fois cette crise
terminée si un jour elle se termine et
donc vouloir aujourd'hui réduire les
droits rendre plus difficile
l'indemnisation des chômeurs alors que
les chômeurs vont être plus nombreux
alors que les gens vont avoir plus de
mal à trouver du travail parce que cette
loi elle peut fonctionner dans un monde
où tout va bien où il ya de la
croissance où il ya beaucoup d'emplois
mais dans un monde où l'emploi est rare
et où les chômeurs sont nombreux c'est
simplement promettre à un nombre de
français grandissant davantage de
précarité et c'est inacceptable puisque
on ne peut pas avoir d'un côté le
discours qui est d'aider les entreprises
et d'essayer d'aider et d'éviter que des
français rentrent dans la précarité et
de l'autre voter des lois qui vont les
précipiter dans la précarité donc il
faut un peu de cohérence
et puis un peu aussi d'adaptation à la
réalité de la situation économique
parce que ce que j'entends aujourd'hui
de la bouche du ministre de l'économie
s'est beaucoup de pensée magique et très
peu de réalité la croissance ne
reviendra pas à son niveau d'avant
qu'ovide avant longtemps
la réforme doit être appliquée au 1er
avril 2021 qu'est ce qui peut se passer
d'ici là de nouvelles manifestations
comme on en a vu un
avant que cette réforme ne soit signé on
se souvient notamment du 49-3 à l'époque
oui oui alors évidemment et je pense que
les mobilisations peuvent reprendre
et elles ont déjà repris 1 puisque la
discussion reprend autour de cette loi
mais c'est toutes ces lois finalement de
casse sociale qui ont été mises en place
mais ronan qu'il appelle des réformes
structurelles loi sur les retraites loi
sur la réforme de l'assurance chômage
qui semble totalement anachronique
compte tenu de la réalité économique de
notre pays de la crise économique
majeure que nous allons traverser suite
à la crise sanitaire
et là on a l'impression que au lieu de
dire on arrête alors il ya ce moratoire
jusqu'en avril 2021 mais avril 2021 sais
rien ce sera le début de la crise
économique donc pourquoi vouloir
continuer s'entêter dans des lois qui
n'ont plus lieu d'être puisque en plus
la dette est en train d'exploser
on s'endette pour aider les entreprises
eh bien il va falloir aussi aider les
personnes et je crois que les aider
c'est ne pas leur rendre plus difficile
la tâche est de trouver du travail et
d'être indemnisés dans un monde où le
travail va se faire rare je le répète
donc il faut être prévoyant ce que n'a
pas été le gouvernement dans cette crise
sanitaire depuis le mois de mars et
anticiper le risque de déclassement de
nombreux françaises et de nombreux
français dans l'année qui vient or
visiblement le gouvernement maintient le
cap s'il ya bien un cap c'est celui là
c'est le moins disant social et c'est la
compétition de tous contre tous dans un
monde où la croissance devrait reprendre
or ce monde là eh bien il n'est pas prêt
de revenir à la normale et est-ce que
vous prédisez des manifestations pour
les semaines à venir au sujet de cette
réforme des retraites alors sur la
réforme des retraites ça dépend de voir
puisque aujourd'hui elle n'est pas
remise officiellement sur la table même
si on voit bien que bruno le maire
partouche parle d'allonger la durée du
temps de travail et de la nécessité des
réformes structurelles que l'union
européenne va aussi orienter la france
vers ces réformes structurelles en
disant attention on veut bien vous
prêtez on veut dire que vous en étiez
sur les marchés financiers mais montrez
que vous allez réformer votre pays vers
ceux moins disant social nécessaire
visiblement pour satisfaire les tenants
de la dette
donc oui sans doute ce débat va revenir
dans l'est dans les semaines les mois
qui viennent si le gouvernement veut
continuer alors que tous les voyants
sont au rouge et que finalement là où
vous pouvez faire ces réformes dans un
monde de croissance et qui allait bien
dans un monde de crise vouloir
précipiter la crise encore davantage
nous semble être criminelle merci alex
et poulain d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes